[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend mit
dem NATO-Gipfel im litauischen Vilnius
verbinden sich hohe Erwartungen nicht
nur auf Seiten der Ukraine vor allem
wird es darum gehen ein Zeichen der
Stärke und Geschlossenheit nach Moskau
zu senden die kleine Überraschung die
der türkische Präsident heute aus dem
Ärmel zauberte machte es nicht leichter
Erdogan wollte ja plötzlich die Aufnahme
Schweden sind die NATO mit dem Beitritt
der Türkei in die eu-koppeln das
Aufstöhnen in den Hauptstädten alle
anderen NATO-Mitglieder konnte man
gerade zu hören wenn sich das Bündnis
noch nicht mal auf die Aufnahme
Schwedens einigen kann weil einer quer
schießt wie will man dann der Ukraine
glaubwürdige Sicherheitsgarantien geben
aber so berichtet Florian neu an
zumindest die Kuh wurde jetzt am Abend
noch vom Eis geholt
das erste was man bei Landung in Vilnius
sieht ist das Flugabwehrsystem Patriot
auf dem Flughafen der litauischen
Hauptstadt hier kommen die
Regierungschefs der NATO an von hier
sind es nur 170 Kilometer zur russischen
Grenze und von hier will die Nato eine
Macht Demonstration aussenden dafür
müsste das Bündnis geschlossen auftreten
das ist seine Aufgabe Generalsekretärs
deutenberg zeichnet einen wunschgipfel
werden wir unsere Abschreckung und
Verteidigung Stärken auch mit höheren
Ausgaben wie werden die Ukraine noch
stärker unterstützen und sie näher an
die NATO heranbringen
doch gegen den Auftritt des türkischen
Präsidenten schützen auch Patriots nicht
mit der Ankunft Erdogans beginnt der
Streit er benutzt Schwedens
Beitrittswunsch in die NATO als
politisches faustand schon vor Abflug
hatte er zu Hause vor heimischer Presse
provoziert
öffnet erst den Weg für den Beitritt der
Türkei zur Europäischen Union und dann
öffnen wir den Weg für Schweden in die
NATO bescheidener im Auftritt die
Ankunft des schwedischen Regierungschefs
auch er kommt früher zum Gipfel um sich
hier mit Erdogan zu treffen
Verhandlungen in letzter Minute für die
er vorher Rückendeckung erhält auch aus
Berlin der Bundeskanzler macht deutlich
dass er eine Verknüpfung des
nato-beitritts Schwedens mit einer
türkischen EU-Perspektive ablehnt die
andere Frage ist eine die damit nicht
zusammenhängt und deshalb finde ich
sollte man das auch nicht als einen
zusammenhängendes Thema verstehen und
dann kommt der Präsident der alle in
Atem hält sie reichen sich die Hände
obwohl der Nato-Generalsekretär
eigentlich die faustballen müsste das
Krisen treffen dass diesen Gipfel vor
einer Blamage bewahren soll und das
solltenberg als Chance verkaufen will
eine positive Entscheidung hier ist
immer noch möglich wir haben keine
Garantie aber natürlich bietet der
Gipfel eine große Chance
erdogan hatte noch eine Nachricht die
Unruhe auf den Gipfel bringt seit seinem
Treffen mit Präsident selenski trommelt
auch eher für einen baldigen Beitritt
der Ukraine in die NATO ein noch
mächtigerer erteilt dieser Diskussion
eine Absage
ich glaube die NATO ist sich nicht einig
darüber die Ukraine jetzt in die
nato-familie aufzunehmen in diesem
Moment wo ein Krieg herrscht
[Musik]
vor wenigen Minuten dann verkündet
solltenberg die völlig überraschende
Wende die Türkei lenkt doch noch ein
da fragen wir doch auch mal da direkt
nach bei Florian neuhahn in Vilnius wie
ist das denn gelungen Erdogan dann doch
noch einzufangen
das war ein wirklich irrer Tag heute sah
nicht nach Einigung aus und dann kam
eben vor wenigen Minuten dann diese
Pressekonferenz mit einer überraschenden
Einigung plötzlich spielt dieser
europäische Beitrittsperspektive also
keine Rolle mehr auf offenbar sondern
der Nato-Generalsekretär hat ihr einen
sieben Punkten Papier vorgestellt eine
Einigung zwischen Schweden und der
Türkei um nur ein paar Punkte
herauszugreifen Schweden verpflichtet
sich zu einer noch mal stärkeren
Verschärfung des Kampfes gegen den
Terror die NATO wiederum will einen
eigenen Anti Terror beauftragten
einrichten und es soll einen
sicherheitspakt geben zwischen Schweden
und der Türkei wie auch immer der
aussehen soll mein Eindruck ist das vor
allem auch der Druck der anderen
NATO-Staaten so vehement und so enorm
war dass Erdogan am Ende sich diesen
Druck offenbar hat beugen müssen jetzt
hat er zugesichert diese Ratifizierung
so schnell wie möglich einzuleiten dann
würde nur noch die Ratifizierung Ungarns
fehlen aber Ungarn hat angekündigt sich
dann der Türkei auch anzuschließen also
es könnte sein dass jetzt die Kuh
wirklich vom Eis ist ich glaube das aber
erst wirklich wenn die Schweden
tatsächlich aufgenommen sind denn auch
vor einem Jahr haben wir bereits hier in
Madrid damals von einem Durchbruch
berichtet der dann doch keiner war auch
noch mal nach bei unserem Türkei
Korrespondenten
von diesem Manöver überhaupt versprochen
also man kann sich natürlich vorstellen
dass er auf der Zielgeraden den Preis
für die Zustimmung der Türkei zum
NATO-Beitritt Schwedens noch mal hoch
treiben wollte und vor allem denke ich
dass er auch nach innen zu seinem Volk
noch mal die Nachricht senden wollte
dass die Türkei eben ein mächtiger
Spieler auf der internationalen Bühne
ist es soll ja am Rande der Gespräche
heute auch ein Treffen gegeben haben mit
EU-Ratspräsident Michelle nachdem
Erdogan eben noch mal gefordert hatte
dass die EU sich da auch bewegt michelle
hatte er den Auftrag nach dem Wahlsieg
Erdogans das Verhältnis zwischen den
Europäern und der Türkei neu zu beleben
erdogan hatte diese Wahlen ja auch vor
allem damit gewonnen dass er eben
herausgestellt hat dass sie Türkei ein
wichtiger Spieler auf der
internationalen Ebene ist jetzt hat es
diese Diskussion heute gegeben und das
heißt dass Erdogan dann auch dem eigenen
Volk den eigenen Medien einen Erfolg
präsentieren kann ich denke dieser
sieben Punkteplan wird die Grundlage
sein dessen was er dann vermutlich
morgen erklären wird er hat halt jetzt
vorgeschlagen dass das türkische
Parlament relativ zügig über den
Beitritt Schwedens abstimmen wird wir
gehen jetzt mal davon aus dass er
empfehlen wird diesem Beitritt auch
zuzustimmen aber wie gesagt glauben kann
man das erst wenn das türkische
Parlament das tatsächlich getan hat
Dankeschön ihr beide nach Vilnius und
nach Istanbul zumindest erhöht das die
Chance dass ich die NATO morgen auf
andere Themen konzentrieren kann dabei
steht sie ja vor einem Dilemma
einerseits soll die Ukraine
sicherheitszusagen bekommen um Russland
abzuschrecken
andererseits fürchten einige naturländer
darunter Deutschland dass das Risiko
direkt in den Krieg hineingezogen zu
werden höher werde als dies über
Waffenlieferungen eh schon der Fall ist
aber selbst über die Frage wie schnell
die Ukraine nach einem Waffenstillstand
beitreten könnte herrscht noch
Uneinigkeit vor allem jene naturländer
die sich von Russland selbst unmittelbar
bedroht fühlen werben dafür der Ukraine
einen schnellen Beitritt in Aussicht zu
stellen zu dieser Gruppe gehört auch
Gastgeberland Litauen das sowohl eine
Grenze zur russischen Enklave
Kaliningrad als auch zu Belarus hat für
das litauische Militär steht außer Frage
dass es ohne die NATO im Rücken kaum
möglich wäre Russland entscheidend
Cornel saulius kuzifizius ist ein Held
in Litauen er hat damals 1991 das
Parlament gegen den Ansturm der
sowjetischen Armee verteidigt die
Barrikaden stehen noch er war damals 24
Jahre alt bereits sich den russischen
Panzern in den Weg zu stellen heute hat
er das Gefühl ist roh wieder ein Angriff
wir müssen wieder Barrikaden bauen wir
müssen Festungen an unseren Außengrenzen
bauen wir müssen zeigen dass wir bereit
sind zurückzuschlagen
gute zifizius wurde ein Elite Soldat
kämpfte in Afghanistan US-Präsident
Busch ehrte ihn nun brauche sein Land
noch mehr militärische Unterstützung des
Westens und der NATO
der Westen muss seine Waffenlieferung
noch intensivieren auch an die Ukraine
sie verteidigt nicht nur sich sondern
uns alle
die litauische Armee hat uns eingeladen
sie will zeigen wie kampfbereit sie ist
es geht tief in die Wälder hinein
morgens um 6 Uhr trainieren Sie für den
Krieg litauen hat eine Grenze zu
Russland und eine zu Belarus beide
Länder bedrohen das Land wie weit ist
der Feind entfernt
drei Soldaten sind gefallen
seit dem ukrainekrieg wissen alle um den
ernst und deshalb wollen viele jetzt
Soldaten sein
[Applaus]
unsere Väter haben schon die
Unabhängigkeit Litauens verteidigt jetzt
müssen wir unser Land beschützen denn
wir lieben unser Vaterland
wenige Kilometer vor Militärgelände
entfernt ist die Grenze zu Belarus dem
treusten Verbündeten Russlands die
Grenzsoldaten dürfen nicht über die
Gefahr sprechen aber sie fürchten dass
dort in Belarus taktischer turmwaffen
stationiert sind ihre Sorgen drücken Sie
vorsichtig aus
das ist ein harter Job an der Grenze vor
allem die Nachtschichten du sitzt in der
Dunkelheit für 12 Stunden musst wach
bleiben hörst auf jedes Geräusch und
wartest ob etwas passiert
wer nach Belarus fahren will muss warten
seit Kriegsbeginn wird genau hingeschaut
die Sanktionen gegen Russland werden
bereits hier umgesetzt viele Waren
dürfen nicht mehr eingeführt werden
engmaschige Kontrolle
die Schlange ist zurzeit sogar sehr kurz
manchmal warte ich acht bis elf Tage
zum Krieg will er nicht sagen er lebt in
Belarus dort spricht man nicht darüber
ich mische mich in die Politik nicht ein
und während sie an der Grenze auf
Einlass warten proben sie in den Wäldern
von Litauen den Widerstand
[Applaus]
und jetzt geht's erstmal den Nachrichten
weiter ein zunächst mit dem
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine aber
einem russischen Angriff auf ein
Wohnviertel in der Region saporisia sind
noch ukrainischen Angaben vier Menschen
getötet worden und mindestens 11 wurden
verletzt der Angriff verfolgte offenbar
als Hilfsgüter an Bedürftige ausgegeben
worden der Gouverneur der Region sprach
von einem Kriegsverbrechen
in Israel will das Parlament am Abend
seine erste Abstimmung über ein
Kernelement der umstrittenen
Justizreform abhalten es sieht vor die
sogenannte angemessenheitsklausel
abzuschaffen und so dem Obersten Gericht
die Möglichkeit zu entziehen
Regierungsentscheidungen als
unangemessen zu bewerten Gegner der
Justizreform befürchten dass dadurch
Korruption und willkürliche
Entscheidungen begünstigt würden morgen
soll es wieder landesweite Proteste
geben
die EU hat einen neuen Rechtsrahmen für
den Datenaustausch mit den USA vorgelegt
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
sagte damit wäre ein sicherer
Datenverkehr für die Europäer
gewährleistet und den Unternehmen auf
beiden Seiten des Atlantiks
Rechtssicherheit geboten die
verbindlichen Regeln begrenzten den
Zugriff von US-Geheimdiensten auf die
Daten von Europäern auf ein notwendiges
und angemessenes Maß so von der Leyen
der im Kreis Sonneberg in Thüringen zum
Landrat gewählte afd-politiker Robert
Sesselmann kann nach einer Überprüfung
seiner Verfassungstreue sein Amt ausüben
das Landesverwaltungsamt teilte mit ist
sie nach der Landratswahl vom Juni
derzeit keinen Grund für ein Eingreifen
die überprüfungssesselmanns war von
Amtswegen gestartet worden hintergrund
ist das Sesselmann dem afd-
der niederländische premiermark rütte
hat seinen Rückzug aus der Politik
angekündigt im Parlament teilte er mit
er werde im Herbst nicht für eine fünfte
Amtszeit kandidieren der rechtsliberale
war knapp 13 Jahre premier der
Niederlande vergangene Woche war seine
vier parteienkoalition am Thema
Migrationspolitik zerbrochen
voraussichtlich Mitte November soll ein
neues Parlament gewählt werden
über das Elterngeld wird ja seit Tagen
diskutiert FDP Bundesfinanzminister
Lindner forderte von der grünen
Familienministerin Paulus das sind ihren
Ressort spart sie schlug vor dass
Elterngeld für Paare mit hohem Einkommen
zu kacken das gefällt der FDP aber nicht
und mitten hinein in diesem Konflikt
kommt jetzt SPD-Chefin weil um die Ecke
mit einem ganz anderen Vorschlag darüber
habe ich mit Ihnen vorhin gesprochen
doch zunächst der Bericht von Heike
kaum hat sich das politische Berlin in
die Sommerferien verabschiedet wird
weiter um die Familienförderung
gestritten neueste Idee Weg mit dem
Ehegattensplitting so könnten auf einen
Schlag Milliarden eingespart werden
diese Debatte muss man ohne Schaum vom
Mund und ohne Ideologie führen sondern
der sacheorientiert und als
Arbeitsminister kann ich nur sagen
Reform der begrüßenswert
Bundesfamilienministerin Pauls hatte
zuletzt die Axt ans Elterngeld für
besser verdienende gelegt um den
sparauftrag der Ampel zu erfüllen der
Vorschlag stößt jedoch bei den
Koalitionspartnern auf wenig gegen Liebe
die Grünen gesprächsbereit
jetzt gibt es unterschiedliche
Vorschläge für eine gerechte
Finanzierung zum Beispiel auch von Lars
Klingbeil von anderen Koalitionspartnern
wir sind hier gerne zum Gespräch bereit
was nicht gehen wird ist dass wir bei
Programmen zu demokratie-förderung
sparen in einer Zeit wo die AFD bei 20
Prozent steht die Abschaffung des
Ehegatten splitting wäre eine massive
Steuererhöhung für die Menschen in
unserem Land vor allem für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft das wäre aus meiner Sicht
außerordentlich unfair ungerecht und
übrigens eine solche Erhöhung eine
solche Steuererhöhung ist auch nicht im
Einklang mit dem Koalitionsvertrag
das Ehegattensplitting eine Erfindung
aus den 1950er Jahren ein
Steuersparmodell für Verheiratete am
größten ist die Ersparnis wenn ein
Partner gar nichts verdient wir fordern
seit langem die Abschaffung des
Ehegattensplittings weil wir der Meinung
sind der Staat muss Kinder fördern und
nicht ihren und gerade auch das
Ehegattensplitting natürlich auch eine
sehr traditionelle
Rollenverteilung und ein sehr
traditionelles Familienbild fördert da
kommt ein neuer Vorschlag der die Bürger
verunsichert Witwenrente dann kürzt man
älter Geld jetzt will man das
Ehegattensplitting verändern was dazu
führt dass der Millionen von Familien
und Frauen betroffen sind ein Vorschlag
der die gem
üter Koalition
dagegen ein bekanntes Muster der
Generalsekretär der FDP warnt vor dem
Hintergrund des Erscheinungsbildes der
gesamten Koalition würde ich empfehlen
nicht ohne Not jetzt Streit vom Zaun zu
brechen und vor allem unnötige
politische keine unnötigen politischen
Baustellen jetzt zu eröffnen kein
Elterngeld für Gutverdiener oder
Steuervorteile für Ehepaare streichen
für die Ampel der nächste
Beziehungsstress
und darüber wollen wir mit dem SPD-Chef
sprechen Lars Klingbeil gerade in seinem
Wahlkreis guten Abend Herr Klingbeil
schönen guten Abend ich frage mal ein
bisschen überspitzt haben sie Angst dass
ihnen über die Sommerpause langweilig
wird oder weil wir so provozieren sie
jetzt den nächsten koalitionskraft
ich glaube weder das mir langweilig ist
noch habe ich das Gefühl dass ich
provoziert habe sondern ich habe mir
eine Woche jetzt angeguckt wie grün und
FDP über die Frage Elterngeld über die
Frage Gleichstellung über die Frage was
können wir für Familien tun geredet
haben auch ein bisschen öffentlich
gestritten haben und ich habe jetzt das
gesagt wofür die SPD steht ein Vorschlag
gemacht der am Ende dazu führt dass wir
mehr für Familien machen mit moderner
Familienpolitik dass wir Chancen
eröffnen auch für Frauen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt das ist der Vorschlag den
ich jetzt als SPD Vorsitzender gemacht
habe und ich glaube das gehört zu einer
Koalition dazu dass man konstruktiv
darüber unterschiedliche Ideen
diskutiert aber so schlimm war es dann
ja jetzt gar nicht mehr zwischen FDP und
grün also Frau Pause und Herrn Lindner
weil sie hatte schon gesagt na gut dann
Kappen wir halt beim Elterngeld man hole
ich da die 500 Millionen her und dann
kommen Sie jetzt und werfen den ganz
neuen Steinen ins Wasser es gibt ja
Ärger auch mit der FDP
wir haben ja im Koalitionsvertrag schon
festgelegt dass wir an Steuerrecht auch
ran wollen dass wir glaube ich alle
sehen dass das jetzige Steuerrecht das
wir haben das ist dazu führt dass gerade
für Frauen und das sind ja häufig
diejenigen die weniger verdienen in
einer Ehe das Anreize da sind dass die
er zu Hause bleiben das muss geändert
werden in einer modernen Familien einer
modernen Gleichstellungspolitik auch in
einer Zeit wo wir übrigens gucken müssen
dass wir Chancen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
viel stärker öffnen also das ist im
Koalitionsvertrag angelegt und ich halte
das für eine sinnvolle Idee dass wir
diese Debatte führen und dass wir am
Ende gucken dass wir nicht bei der
Gleichstellungspolitik Rückschritte
machen sondern eher gucken wie wir
Konflikt auch nach vorne auflösen aber
angelegt ist das natürlich ein schönes
Wort also nirgendwo im Koalitionsvertrag
steht drin Abschaffung des ehegattes
es steht drin dass wir das Steuerrecht
überarbeiten wollen und jetzt sage ich
auch mal ein bisschen selbstbewusst als
Parlamentarier ist jetzt ja die Zeit wo
die Bundesregierung den Haushalt
vorgelegt hat und wo jetzt darüber
diskutiert wird wie geht man im
Parlament mit welchen Maßnahmen vor also
es ist jetzt auch die Zeit von
Parlamentariern von Abgeordneten
Vorschläge zu machen wie als SPD haben
nie versteckt dass wir dafür sind dass
Ehe ganz splitting abzuschaffen dass wir
dafür sind gerade für ihn jetzt in
Zukunft geschlossen werden eben dieses
antiquierte System zu überwinden dass
wir Anreiz auch setzen wollen dafür dass
Frauen stärker Chancen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt eröffnet bekommen und jetzt
kann sich da jeder inhaltlich zu
verhalten die FDP verhält sich ja schon
die ja bekanntlich auch das
Finanzministerium stellt und sagt das
ist eine Steuererhöhung quasi durch die
Hintertür mit dem Deckmantel es ging um
Gleichberechtigung
dann muss man mein Interview genau lesen
ich habe gesagt wir wollen das für
zukünftig geschlossene in Einrichten
nicht für die die jetzt schon sich mit
diesem Modell auch über Jahre über
Jahrzehnte eingerichtet haben aber
wissen Sie die Europäische Kommission
die OECD alle kritisieren dass wir
dieses System haben ein System das am
Ende dazu führt dass Frauen auch gut
ausgebildete Frauen sich am Ende
entscheiden er zu Hause zu bleiben nicht
dem Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung zu stehen
obwohl sie es eigentlich wollten weil
diese Steuersystem diejenigen begünstigt
wo der Mann viel verdient die Frau wenig
das führt dazu dass die Frau zu Hause
bleibt und ich finde das gehört zu einer
modernen Familie einer modernen
Gleichstellungspolitik dazu dass man das
in Frage stellt das haben wir während
der koalitionsverhandlung schon getan es
ist im Koalitionsvertrag angelegt dass
wir die Steuerklassen ändern wollen und
das ist richtig das ist ja dann mein
Teil noch zu dieser Diskussion beitragen
Änderung ist natürlich eine technische
mit der Steuerklasse 4 brauchen wir
nicht weiter ausführen hat aber nichts
damit zu tun dass man das Ehegatten im
Effekt ab
schafft aber sie argumentieren ja
durchaus auch fiskalisch also mit der
Einnahmeseite und sagen dann können wir
uns da an der Stelle sparen und dann
brauchen wir stattdessen diese Kappung
beim Elterngeld nicht passt das denn
eigentlich zu SPD dass man sich damit
indirekt für diejenigen einsetzt die
mehr als 150 180.000 Bruttoeinkommen im
Jahr haben warum besorgen Sie sich so um
die ich
setze mich nicht für Leute ein die
180.000 Euro zu verstehen ist
Jahreseinkommen haben da habe ich viele
Ideen und die können wir jetzt SPD gerne
morgen präsentieren diese Ideen wie
Menschen die viel Geld verdienen die
hohes Einkommen haben in der
Gesellschaft dazu beitragen können dass
sie mehr Verantwortung übernehmen und
dass sie auch mehr Steuern bezahlen aber
das Elterngeld ist keine Sozialleistung
das Elterngeld ist eingeführt worden aus
Aspekten der Gleichstellung um dafür zu
sorgen dass Frauen viel stärker die
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
ausgleichen können dass sie stärker dem
Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung stehen wenn
man jetzt einfach kappt egal an welcher
Grenze dann führt das am Ende dazu dass
mehr Frauen zu Hause bleiben das weniger
Frauen dem Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung
stehen und ein solchen Weg finde ich
nicht richtig und deswegen habe ich ein
Vorschlag gemacht wie wir die
Herausforderung die ja finanzpolitisch
Stars wie wir sie anders lösen können
ohne dass wir beim Elterngeld
Einschränkung vornehmen ohne dass wir in
der Frage der Gleichstellung
Rückschritte machen müssen danke für das
Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
auf die ampelparteien hier zu einer
gemeinsamen Reform finden da darf man
wohl getrost ein Fragezeichen setzen ein
anderes Reformvorhaben ist heute
hingegen einen gehörigen Schritt
vorangekommen Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach und die Gesundheitsminister
der Länder haben sich auf Eckpunkte
einer kranken hausreform geeinigt auch
dem ging ein csringen voraus bis auf
zwei Länder Bayern und
Schleswig-Holstein stimmten nun alle zu
zumindest in den Grundzügen die Details
sollen in den nächsten Wochen folgen was
damit auf Kliniken und Patienten zukommt
erklärt Britta Spiekermann
es sieht nicht gut aus als heute Mittag
die Gespräche zur klinikreform beginnen
Laumann Gesundheitsminister aus NRW
stellt sich auf eine lange Sitzung ein
wie viel Zeit haben Sie unsere
Familienkalender
Pressekonferenz ja nein vielleicht wenn
überhaupt dann spät dann sind doch alle
an ihrem Platz früher als gedacht die
Eckpunkte für die lang umkämpfte
klinikreform stehen es ist die Vorstufe
für einen Gesetzentwurf nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
es ist eine Art Revolution weil es ist
die Abkehr von den Fallpauschalen es ist
der Umbau des Systems im Sinne dass die
Anreize ganz andere sein werden wir
lösen das System der Fallpauschalen ab
und deswegen bin ich heilfroh dass wir
dieses Zeitfenster wo das Fenster offen
steht für diese Reform genutzt haben
sondern Fenster steht nicht ewig offen
dieses offene Fenster heißt in der
klinikreform Transparenz jeder soll
online erkennen können mit welcher
Klinik er es zu tun hat Grundversorger
Fachklinik oder Maximalversorger
Leistungsgruppen soll es geben also was
bietet eine Klinik an und
Qualitätsstandards etwa wie oft wird
eine bestimmte Behandlung durchgeführt
wer gut ist bekommt Geld nur einer ist
dagegen fürchtet vehement um die
ländliche Versorgung Bayerns
Gesundheitsminister stimmt mit Nein
schließlich-holstein enthält sich
ansonsten Zufriedenheit warum dann den
Fehler suchen es sind die müssen viele
Kliniken werden sterben wie aber sollen
die Krankenhäuser den Reformprozess
überleben die noch mit Finanzspritzen zu
retten wären da gibt es einen
transformationsfonds in denen werden
Bund und Länder einzahlen das wird
gesteckt es wird gespeist durch Mittel
der Krankenkassen aber keine Mittel der
Krankenkassen die Vormärz schon in der
stationären Versorgung verbraucht und
sowas somit zusätzliches Geld
zusätzliches Geld dass die Krankenkassen
nicht haben stehen sie doch selbst unter
Druck werden weitere
Beitragssteigerungen in Kauf genommen
und da gibt es noch einen weiteren Haken
der Bund hat überhaupt kein Geld um in
den Fonds einzuzahlen es bleibt die
Quadratur des Kreises auch wenn an
diesem Tag von Durchbruch und Revolution
die Rede ist das gehört als man sich an
diesem Nachmittag voneinander
verabschiedet zur Wahrheit dazu
und mit anderen Wirtschaftsthemen geht
es jetzt bei dir weiter heiß die
Baupreise für Wohngebäude in Deutschland
haben sich weiter erhöht der Anstieg hat
sich allerdings etwas verlangsamt das
zeigen die neuen Zahlen der
statistischen Bundesamts für den Mai
verlangsamte Teuerung ist aber auch
Teuerung um wie viel denn Frank Wittmann
ja umfasst neun Prozent da wird es
weniger Häuslebauer trösten dass die
Preise zumindest statistisch so langsam
gestiegen sind wie seit zwei Jahren
nicht mehr das beispielsweise die Preise
für Zimmer und Holzbauarbeiten sogar
leicht gesunken sind unterm Strich
zeigen die Preis Pfeile auch im Mai
mehrheitlich nach oben teilweise immer
noch sehr deutlich besonders gilt dies
für Heizanlagen ein Plus von fast 15
Prozent und auch Dachdeckerarbeiten
verteuern sich weiter hier ein Anstieg
von beinahe 11% da fällt es schwer von
einer Trendwende zu sprechen es bleibt
dabei immer mehr Menschen neben Abstand
vom Baum die gestiegenen Zinsen tun ihr
übriges und was heißt das für die
bauziele der Bundesregierung mehr
Wohnraum schaffen zu wollen ja es geht
komplett in die falsche Richtung statt
mehr werden zunehmend weniger Wohnungen
gebaut das Ifo-Institut beispielsweise
erwartet einen Rückgang beim Wohnungsbau
auf etwa 200.000 Wohnungen im Jahr 2025
das werden nur noch halb so viel
Wohneinheiten wie von der
Bundesregierung als Ziel ausgegeben
neben den steigenden Preisen belastet
auch dass der Bund die Neubauförderung
drastisch zurückgefahren hat Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
in Jamaika berät die internationale
meeresbodenbehörde über den Umgang mit
wertvollen Bodenschätzen in der Tiefsee
besonders im Pazifik gibt es Gebiete die
Reichen Metallen wie Kupfer Kobalt und
Nickel sind gestern war eine Frist
abgelaufen innerhalb derer der Tiefsee
Bergbau weltweit reguliert werden sollte
ob es überhaupt zum Abbau kommen sollte
ist jedoch umstritten experten fürchten
Schäden am Ökosystem des Meeres
am ersten Wettkampftag der para
Leichtathletik WM in Paris hat
Weitspringer Leon Schäfer dem deutschen
Team mit einem Weltrekord gleich das
erste Gold beschert und sich den zweiten
WM-Titel im prothesenweitsprung schaffte
der 26-Jährige aus Leverkusen nach zwei
ungültigen Versuchen und erst im letzten
Anlauf 7 Meter 25 und verbesserte so
seine eigene weltbest-marke um einen
Zentimeter
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt vor
Hitze im Süden und Südwesten genaueres
dazu und auch sonst zur Wetterlage
gleich von Katja horneffer er ist noch
kurz der Blick auf heute wo sich teils
heftige Gewitter entlüden wie hier im
sächsischen Erzgebirgskreis inklusive
Temperatursturz von 30 auf 20 Grad auch
in Göppingen Baden-Württemberg vielen in
wenigen Minuten große Mengen Regen und
auch Hagel bevor die Gewitterzellen dann
weitergezogen
ja gleich noch mehr Wetter und dann geht
es mit dem ZDF montagskino weiter und um
0 Uhr gibt es dann unsere heute schnell
Update mit Nasen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend gestern war der bislang
heißeste Tag des Jahres bis zu 38 Grad
im Südwesten gemessen in Waghäusel
Kirrlach heute war es ein bisschen
weniger heiß aber schon morgen nimmt die
Hitze einen neuen Anlauf von Südwesten
und dann wird es wieder schwül heiß und
gewittrig und zum späten Nachmittag und
Abend drohen Gewitter im Saarland und
den Baden-Württemberg einzelne kleine
Gewitter gibt es auch noch heute Nacht
zum Beispiel hier im alten Vorland sonst
ist es häufig klar dass bildet sich
Nebel die Temperaturen sinken auf 17
Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und bis 11
Grad in der Lüneburger Heide und morgen
liegen dann die Höchsttemperaturen an
den Küsten und den Schleswig-Holstein
bei 25 bis 27 Grad sonst wird's heiß die
Temperaturen von 31 bis 38 Grad und
besonders belastend wird die Hitze
wieder im Südwesten genauso wie schon
gestern der Tag beginnt erstmal mit viel
Sonne und einigen Wolkenfeldern im
Nordwesten nachmittags brodelt dann im
Westen und zum späten Nachmittag und
Abend kann es dann kräftige Gewitter
geben im oder andere de
Baden-Württemberg Gewitter die mit Hagel
Platzregen und Sturmböen verbunden sein
können diese Gewitter ziehen im Laufe
der Nacht zu Mittwoch dann weiter
nordwärts auch am Mittwoch gibt es noch
Schauer und Gewitter dann aber ist die
schwule Hitze aus Deutschland weggeräumt
Donnerstag und Freitag wird es deutlich
angenehmer bei Höchsttemperaturen von 20
bis 30 Grad ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend